i i gotta give a shout out i gotta give
a shout out we're sitting here we're
criticizing the media yes and there's
someone in the media who deserves some
respect and people are not gonna want to
accept it but we're
we're uh um people of principle anna
kasparian of the young turks checks out
from the daily wire quote i was wrong
young turks kasparian admits she bought
into false written house narrative
mad respect 100 wow disagree with their
politics i think the young turks have
been very unfair to me i think they've
lied about me on more than one occasion
jenk yeuger screamed at me at politicon
for no reason when i've known the guy
for years and i politely asked him like
hey you guys put up a smear piece on
dave rubin but like my name's like in
the thumbnail in the middle and they
starts yelling at me
all of that aside
if you recognize that you're wrong and
you correct it
i will give you the respect you deserve
because if we if we still you know if
someone comes out and says you know i
bought into this false narrative on cal
written us which is what annexperian did
and then we refuse to accept their
acknowledgement you only encourage them
to keep doing bad
we tell them thank you for for saying
the right thing with with respect and
hopefully they continue to do the right
thing do the research
looking at these tweets from people
they keep saying
crossing state lines with a gun crossing
state lines with a gun they keep saying
assault rifle assault rifle
wrong
these people have not done
any
any research into this at all
and if they do i'll give them the
respect they deserve well that's big
that she came out and corrected her
statement because if we remember i mean
the mainstream media especially msnbc
they were calling kyle a domestic
terrorist a mass murderer they were
using extremely hyperbola hyperbolic
language in order to kind of inflame
this situation there's people trying to
make this about race and again this has
nothing to do with any of that but when
it comes to this kind of salacious
action someone actually saying hey i was
actually wrong here is very big because
the mainstream media doubled down
tripled down and they're still trying to
ignore a lot of important facts in this
case they didn't know what happened but
they still were able to declare
definitely domestic terrorists
definitely a mass murderer again we're
still finding out all the details of the
case here and the picture portrayed here
is totally different i saw a really
funny tweet you know you know why i love
to shout out as cameron caskey because
you know he seemed like somebody who was
acting in good faith initially but he's
totally just lost any will to be honest
he tweeted something really funny he
tweeted how come all of something i'm
paraphrasing how come all of these
centrists are so much smarter than me
and i thought it was really funny
because he's you know he's being
sarcastic he's saying they're not
but i realized that's the attitude that
many of these establishment democrat
types and leftists have where they don't
actually read the news they don't know
what they're talking about but they're
arrogant enough to get online and say
these things and there are tribalist
individuals who are willing to retweet
it because it makes them feel good
inside but when you come out and say
assault rifle when literally not a
single person in kenosha had an assault
rifle not a single person
i'm not going to play stupid semantic
games
they meant long gun
not assault rifle but they but saying
that is factually and legally wrong and
they don't bother to do a google search
a google search five seconds to figure
out what an assault rifle is they don't
even do that they get verified they get
a million followers and then they tweet
i'm smarter than you i prefer duckduckgo
but that's just the separate topic
well you know i was thinking that a lot
of these people's perceptions on this
are prejudiced from the actions that
facebook and gofundme took very early on
right right so if facebook
if facebook where grandma shares
pictures of her cats
tells me that written house is clearly
guilty and you get suspended
i don't know they remember the details
but they did ban and censor some
elements about this and gofundme
definitely took down his fundraiser well
then it must be true because facebook is
a benign entity where my pictures of my
grandkids are getting likes from all of
our cousins
social media took people down for
talking about facts of this case so
that's that's absolutely huge people
were prevented from having a discussion
what was going on here we only got
mainstream media dribble and assertions
and then everyone else less everyone
else left talking about this was scared
of being targeted and taken down there's
people demonetized there's people who
lost their channels there's people who
were eviscerated and deleted unpersoned
because they were discussing the facts
here there was a really good tweet from
the libertarian party i think it may
have been of new hampshire i'm not sure
they
uh this account highlighted two tweets
one was from a leftist who said that cal
rittenhouse was a white supremacist who
was hunting down
civil rights protesters which is a lie
right and the other tweet said based on
the evidence in this trial it's clear
that kyle was acting in self-defense
the self-defense tweet got suspended
and the white supremacist tweet massive
retweets oh there's this guy brooklyn
dad defiant or whatever he's got
something like a million million
followers just constantly railing on
this constantly telling people
a million followers verified on twitter
look at sean king dude right these
people built careers off intentionally
misleading and this is this has been the
the mo of the establishment for the past
as i mean maybe maybe for longer than we
realize but you get russiagate they
accuse trump of doing what they
literally did the the clintons and and
the democrats had more ties to russia
and the and this manipulation and lies
than trump ever did and they put out
fake news and the media helped him now
you then you you get sean king and there
was that time he falsely accused that
cop of abusing that woman or whatever
there's a video he put out where he
claimed proud boys had gone done
something that proud boys weren't even
involved in he just lies he knows it and
many leftists have called him out he's
still got a million plus followers he
gets hired at these companies like the
intercept in the daily news or whatever
he gets paid lots of money then you get
brooklyn dad to find it turns out he's
being paid by political operatives that
was a big expose i could be wrong about
that but it's my understanding at the
very least that he was being he's a paid
political operative and even leftist
criticized him for it you have a massive
propaganda machine
pumping out lies making money their
grifters what do they do
they know they have to accuse us
to deflect so they'll say when we pull
up video or we pull up news articles and
and challenge them and show you you know
what's going on in the trial the other
day we played the actual video from
msnbc and in the trial to disprove their
lies
they'll claim we're the ones who are
manipulating people when brian selter
tells people don't watch the propaganda
come to us when i think it was cuomo and
he said you can't legally you're not
legally allowed to read wikileaks only
we can
anyone who tells you not to seek out
information is manipulating you because
i'll tell you this watch cnn see what
they say read the new york times see
what they say and then watch crowder
watch david pakman watch the young turks
and watch us try and get as much as you
can because then you'll see through the
lies what do they tell you don't listen
to the grifters they're manipulating you
man this is one reason why you got to be
in good shape guys because
you need stamina
to withstand this constant barrage of
lies manipulation disinformation if you
are weak if you're physically weak if
you're mentally emotionally spiritually
weak
you're just going to fall victim you're
just going to be led right off the cliff
away from the truth and into ways that
are going to end up harming you in the
long run if you follow all the
mainstream narratives i agree with tim
on some points here especially when it
comes to seeing what the larger media
landscape actually looks like but
remember after watching the mainstream
media remember to squeegee clean your
third eye and uh try to decompress
and uh you know
because seriously there's a lot of like
trauma-based mind control and a lot of
psychological tricks and dirty tricks
used by the mainstream media it's
absolutely just
when you when you watch it it's like
watching another reality it's like
watching another world and and truly you
have to be very careful with what they
say because you have to fact check
everything and when usually when you do
even in things even with basic things
that you think are common you're shocked
and surprised by just simply trying to
look at the evidence yourself what
they're saying and what the actual truth
of the reality the difference is so
stark that it's difficult to accept
sometimes and you and you think to
yourself
nah that can't be possibly right and you
and you doubt your own perspective they
can't be lying that much right
and then when you think about what we're
just witnessing in real time right now
and then you just think about all
written history and then then it's just
like oh god
when we had uh we had steve hilton on
the other day
and when we were showing the video of
the guy on msnbc i don't know his name
and he was like gage grosskroyd's
testified that his hands were up when he
was shot
and then i played it i play the video
where the defense is like it wasn't
until you pointed the gun at cal
rittenhouse that he fired on you and he
goes correct
he didn't believe it he was like no like
how could they just say that
and i'm like the videos published after
after the testimony the articles even if
even if the article came out right
before that testimony and they rushed it
they haven't corrected it and he was
just like i can't believe they would
outright and overtly lie like that and
i'm like i can't i tried i tried to tell
somebody you remember uh the portland
shooting uh where the antifa guys uh
shot the uh that jay afraid jay daniels
aaron daniels aaron danielson and uh
nickname j right and i and there was a
guy who filmed it live who was just
allegedly strolling along the street and
happened to pick up the entire thing on
video right so i got in touch with the
guy and i interviewed him and i went
through it frame by frame by frame and
asked him all the questions then i asked
him why he was going to the protests and
he says oh my daughter got me into going
to these things black lives matter and
you know i just want to support her i'm
like oh you're a family man yeah you
believe in family right you're a good
dad you like leading your family like
having a whole intact family yeah well
did you know that black lives matter is
opposed to the nuclear family that wants
to quote disrupt the norm around the
nuclear family he's like nah i'm like
hold on a second
i pulled it up i showed it to him he
read it and he and his reaction was
oh that just must be a typo
that just must be a mistake they did
delete that they took it down he did
delete it because it was so egregious
and outrageous but it is true it's part
of their platform it's what they believe
and a guy i put it right in front of him
on the website everything and he still
could not believe
that he was supporting an organization
that was against his whole raison d'etre
being a dad and leading a fan drives me
nuts when people say i can't believe it
when something happens especially you
watch sports announcers oh he caught the
catch i can't believe it like dude
believe it it happened stop telling
yourself you can't believe what's right
in front of you i think one of the one
of the big problems that we're seeing
now especially with the right is that
they keep saying things like why would
someone want there to be no justice
you know they're like the the people who
are cheering for kyle rittenhouse to go
to prison are cheering the destruction
of our justice system why would you want
that and i'm just like you'd think after
this many years you'd realize that
communists who scream long live the
revolution this guy gage gross corrects
testified he did hold up his fist are
you are you affiliated though did you go
to their things yes
did you speak at them he said are you a
member are you a member he said no no
but you've spoken at their events yes so
you're affiliated yes did you just chant
the slogans did you raise your fist and
say long live the revolution yes what
people need to understand and that's
what i was trying to say to steve the
other day
when you assume that your political
rival holds the same moral framework and
worldview as you you are wrong you're
making assumptions when these people say
long live the revolution and then you
wonder why it is they're lying under
oath they do not respect our moral
framework they do not agree with our
moral framework they do not respect the
authority of the court and they believe
they have a right by any means necessary
to subvert and destroy this system i was
surprised when he actually admitted
bicep guy i don't like using their names
i call him the n-word guy and the bicep
guide skateboard guy uh he i was
actually surprised that he just straight
up was like yeah he didn't point the gun
at me until i pointed the gun to him
well he tried denying it at first but he
admitted it he had to though that was
what was so crazy about the testimony
the defense was like even so i still was
surprised but check it out the defense
said to him first you pointed your gun
at kyle rittenhouse and then he fired
upon you and gross quartz goes
no
and then he was like he pulls the video
up and he hands him a phone and goes
that's a photo what is it of and he's
like it's my bicep being vaporized and
he's like and your gun is pointed at the
defendant he's like yes and that's when
he shot you yes so it was only after you
advanced on the defendant pointed your
gun at him then he fired on you he goes
yes
when you're showing a picture to the
jury what's the dude going to say no he
tried that he tried
true this guy has no allegiance to the
prosecutor the prosecutor's already put
himself in a position where he can't
criminally charge him so he's like
that's on you i'm not gonna make myself
look worse and incriminate myself
and there you go dang i understand that
that's like what's called perjury you
just lied to the jury under oath yep
but but this is a mat the issue is a big
difference between like hard perjury and
an interpretation
so when he's like
you know it wasn't until you pointed the
gun he's like no
and then well here's the video oh yeah i
guess so it's very different from them
and this dude lied a lot it was funny
when the prosecutor playing the video
with gage gross kreitz holding his gun
and he goes so at this point you've
pulled your gun as you're approaching
kyle written house and he goes
no
and this prosecutor is like here's the
video we just played with a gun in your
hand and he goes yes
this dude is lying the worst but perjury
almost never my understanding is almost
never gets prosecuted and it's typically
for like were you at the bar at 2 am no
i was in buffalo new york and then they
find a picture of you there you overtly
lied about what you were doing and then
they might try and you knowingly spy on
the american people
that's james clapper by the way
committing perjury that's right and and
everything and unfortunately when him
and schiff and all of these these
cronies went on tv and lied about
russiagate they weren't under oath when
they were under oath in congressional
testimony they admitted i have no
evidence it's not true it's all bunk
that's that's one of my favorite things
talking to cash and pointing all that
stuff out i'm so glad that he was on the
show what a good dude thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm now
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you